oh hi I'm Missy gadelle I'm a chemical
engineering student at the University of
Minnesota I'd like you to explain your
work in a drawing no problem I take this
pen and this sheet of paper and what I
can do with I cannot explain the wood
spintronics in a few minutes but I can
explain for example the giant
magnetoresistance geumja so I suppose
that on the way of the electron in a
conductor I put two thin layer of
magnetic material and I suppose further
that the magnetization are in the
opposite direction this is a North Pole
yes on the top and the South Pole is at
the bottom of this layer it's not spall
yeah
and so the basic physics is that the
electron depending on the spin can cause
this layer is a spin is parallel to the
magnetization so this one will be able
to cause this layer but then will not be
able to cause a second one it will be
reflected
if one consider the spin down electrons
there as I cannot cross even the first
layer so the current is stupid by this
association of two layers with opposite
magnetization not totally but all this
is is same situation so now I suppose
that that by applying a magnetic field I
align the magnetization of the two layer
then for the spinner policy spinner will
be able to cause surface one but also
the second one the spin on electron will
be repelled of course but the Alpha the
current will be able to cause the
your systems and this opened the way to
the currents this is the concept of GMO
a magnetic field lining the
magnetization of two-layer and opening
the way to the electrical currents this
is what you use in your computer you've
detect the magnetic field generated by
the magnetic beats line the
magnetization of two layers this open
the weight of the current and you can
detect the magnetic bit in fact this
works if this spin up cannot flip spins
during the travel between the two layers
in fact each one knows that he will keep
his spin only on a short distance of a
few nanometers and so what is necessary
is that the distance between the two
layer must be short with me in the
nanometer scale and this is why also
spintronics the cool start only with the
beginning of the nanotechnologies